[Music]  that's definitely a look you can say  that again  Gweneth Paltrow debuted her engagement  ring on Saturday at The Producers Guild  Awards and this bling is no joke  excuse me yeah we're a pretty shook over  Gwen stunning giant rock the deep blue  sparkler was hard to miss on the  actresses left ring finger as she  presented her fiance Brad Feld chucks  producing partner Ryan Murphy with the  Norman Lear Achievement Award in  television et was on hand at the event  Murphy couldn't help but gush over  Gweneth and their long-lasting  friendship she is an amazing person and  very you know involved in my children's  life in my life she's just she's true  and she's I get emotional talking member  she's just like the best everything I  ever ever wanted from her came true you  know it wasn't what I thought my  friendship with her could be when if  it's funny she likes a good joke  she's just great she's fun  [Music]  you